it's a big moment for these naked
mole-rats
time to clean the cage unlike others of
their species these cuties don't live in
semi-arid eastern Africa but in a lab in
the German capital Berlin keeper
Gabriele upfronts makes sure they feel
right at home
they're very agile and lively and their
skin is so smooth as you can see it's
hard to hold on to one for long in the
wild naked mole-rat spend most of their
time underground in tunnel systems this
is where they usually sleep and in this
area here where the exercise wheel is
that's the gym and they usually go to
the bathroom back there naked mole rats
live in colonies that for a mammal are
unusual similar to social insects like
bees and ants they have workers soldiers
and a queen who bears all the colonies
young and evolution has adapted them to
survive in extreme environments they've
developed a range of exceptional
characteristics that fascinate
scientists from different fields
molecular biologist Gary Lewin has
worked with the rodents for years the
aim of my group is really to try and
discover what are the molecular changes
that were wrought by evolution what what
are the specific changes in the genome
that allowed the animal to become so
extreme he and his team have decoded the
cellular mechanisms that make the naked
mole-rat largely immune to stimuli that
are painful for other animals these
results could help human pain patients
the scientists are also chasing down
another lead they've discovered in the
animals genome naked mole rats don't
seem to show any signs of aging and for
rodents they can live extraordinarily
long lives
because they live for 30 years without
any apparent diseases it might help us
to work out what special metabolism they
have that protects them from getting
diseases like diabetes or cardiovascular
disease cancels and these these sorts of
things
feeding time naked mole-rats of
vegetarians and they don't drink water
the food they eat has enough to fulfill
their needs
that's another adaptation to an arid
environment and mole rat burrows don't
have to be well ventilated these rodents
don't have a problem with low oxygen
environments this is actually
fundamentally a very interesting
phenomena because it could be used in
people because one of the major medical
problems that is that we have is is
brain damage through stroke and brain
damage through stroke is essentially
just a hypoxic situation because naked
mole rats breed quite slowly
the researchers mustn't injure or kill
them in the quest to decipher their
genetic secrets so much of their work is
done on kidney cell samples that have
been multiplied with the help of modern
replication methods produced from these
kidney cells stem cells in order to
create different cell lines such as
neurons or let's say pancreas cells to
do other kind of experiments in this way
we don't always need a naked mole rat or
a naked mole rat tissue to work with we
can use these cells too for doing
experiments the animals Keeper wants
them to be as happy and healthy as
possible for Gabriela plants the work is
more than just a job if I'm annoyed
about something or stressed out and then
come here and take care of them the
stress just disappears it really calms
me down when it comes to naked mole rats
many unsolved puzzles remain but
scientists are working hard to solve
them